Joe: From Wendy's to Quiznos,
we wanted to find out all the biggest
portion-size differences
between UK and US fast food.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, Wendy's iconic
Frostys come in three sizes.
Junior, regular, and large.
In the US, we actually
have four Frosty sizes.
Junior, small, medium, large.
We're going to pour out the largest Frosty
to see how big it is compared to the US's.
The classic hamburger at a
Wendy's is called a Dave's,
named after the founder, Dave Thomas.
Ours come in singles,
doubles, and triples.
Our burgers are the same in the UK.
They also come as singles,
doubles, or triples.
Joe: Now we're going to weigh a US triple.
Pretty close. 14 ounces for our triple.
Now, while a triple might
be the official limit
on burger sizes at Wendy's,
Wendy's enthusiasts
have come up with something
called a meat cube.
This is a secret menu item
where you actually take
an extra meat patty
and add it to this, so
you get four patties,
which I think adds up to around a pound.
Joe, I'm officially challenging
you to a meat cube showdown.
The fastest person to eat
the entire meat cube wins.
You think you got it?
I accept your challenge, Harry.
Let's do this!
Harry: Three, two, one.
Joe: And start.
All right.
It's a lot of beef.
I see why the triple is the limit now.
Time?
Conner: 1:07.
I wish I had more time to chew it.
[coughing]
Need the sauce. Need some moisture.
The buns!
Oh, God.
[Joe yelling]
How'd I do?
Done.
Yeah!
Whoo!
USA, baby!
Conner: How do you feel?
Terrible. I feel absolutely terrible.
And yet, elated that I won.
Well, now we know why the US
has such an obesity problem.
OK, that's quite enough of that.
Back to our regularly
scheduled programming.
[beep]
Another iconic Wendy's
menu item is the Baconator.
In the UK, these just come
in one size, as a regular.
Of course, in the US, we
also have the Baconator,
but we have a smaller Baconator,
known as the Son of Baconator.
Something incredibly unsettling
about a burger having a
child that's also a burger.
This Baconator giving
birth to that Baconator.
Harry: And, of course, we're
going to weigh the regular
Baconators to see whose is bigger.
The highly regarded
Wendy's nuggets that
come in regular or spicy.
Love the spicy.
They come in units of four, six, and 10.
Nuggets in the UK only
come in two portion sizes,
four and eight.
Wendy's, of course, has fries.
And those fries in the
US come in four sizes.
Junior, small, medium, large.
Our fries also come in four sizes.
Value, small, medium, and large.
Let's weigh our large fries
to see who's getting more.
Ours is way less.
Hm. What's that all about?
[beep]
Another side that is
probably unique to Wendy's,
I can't think of any other
fast-food place that does this,
is Wendy's chili.
It has been on the menu
since it opened back in 1969.
In the US, you can get your chili,
ugh, for whatever reason,
in two sizes, small and large.
In the UK, we only have one size of chili,
which is this one.
We're going to weight it
against the largest size in
the US to find the difference.
Finally, let's compare drinks.
In the US, you can get
three sizes of drink.
Small, medium, and large.
On the internet, it does not specify
how much fluid ounces are in any of these.
If I had to guess,
too much, way too much,
way, way too much.
In the UK, drinks come in three sizes.
Small, medium, or large.
And these are advertised as being
12, 16, and 20 ounces, respectively.
Let's measure the largest drinks
to see which country's is bigger.
Fizzy.
So, our large drink actually came out
as closer to 18 ounces than closer to 20.
I will say that in the UK,
you fill up your own drink,
so maybe I just needed to fill a bit more.
OK, so their large is 18 ounces.
What is our small?
20 ounces. So our small is
bigger than their large.
Man, we love drinking our
calories in this country.
The fountain drinks at
Popeyes come in three sizes.
The small, which is 22 ounces,
the medium, which is 30 ounces,
and the large, which is,
of course, 40 ounces.
40 ounces.
That's so much soda.
In the UK, drinks only come in two sizes,
as a kids size or as a regular size.
We're not sure how much
is in either of these,
so we're going to measure them both.
A little over 300.
About 450.
But those aren't the biggest, I say!
Actually, at the Popeyes in the US,
you can also get a gallon of sweet tea
[thud]
and unsweetened tea.
One. Whole. Gallon.
[grunts] Look at this.
Gallon, gallon.
Oh, and don't you hate when dummies
do that thing where they're like,
"Hey, the medium is the
same size as the large!"
And it never is, it's,
like, a total con, so.
Medium soda, large cup.
Oh, wow, guys!
The medium's about the
same size as the large,
except for, like, oh, I
don't know, 10 ounces.
Dumb TikTokers, you guys don't even know.
You're out of your league, TikTokers!
I'm the fast-food king online!
All right?
When was this cleaned last?
Ooh!
I'm gonna go 36, what do you think?
I mean, it could have been the amount
to top of this cup, but again,
you can't fill this to the brim.
You have to put a cap on it.
In the UK, fries just
come as a regular serving.
US, we got two Popeyes fries sizes.
A regular and a large.
The regular, as we have here,
just came with a side of
the three-piece we got here.
And, of course, a large,
which is a box of just fries.
Harry: We're going to weigh these to see
how they compare to the US.
Joe: We, of course, now, are going to
also weigh our largest fry.
Do not sleep on these fries.
You'll be surprised to learn
that the inside of this
scale is disgusting.
A Popeyes chicken
sandwich in the UK weighs
exactly 250 grams.
Joe: In the US, it weighs
270 grams.
In the US, Popeyes signature chicken
comes in seven serving sizes.
We'll start with these.
So, of course, the one-piece kids meal.
Then you can upgrade to
a two-piece regular meal,
which comes with a side and a biscuit.
Or you can get yourself the three-piece.
And a four-piece. Side and a biscuit.
From there, you can get yourself
an eight-piece family meal.
The 12-piece, for the family as well,
or just for one person over a weekend.
And the largest, the 16-piece.
Are you kidding me? [laughs]
How absurd is this?
Look at all this chicken!
In the UK, the signature chicken comes
as a two-piece meal,
as a three-piece meal,
or as a six-piece sharer,
as a nine-piece sharer,
or our largest size, the 12-piece sharer.
Let's weigh a wing, a thigh, and a leg
to see whose chickens are bigger.
So, in the UK, our thigh,
leg, and wing combo
came to around 290 grams.
Here we go. First guy up, the leg.
Next up, got that ♪ wing ♪
Kind of a wimpy-looking one.
And this one, the thigh.
How 'bout the tendies?
In the US, we have these following sizes.
A kids meal has a one-piece,
but what's up, they gave us two!
And then from there,
you get a three-piece,
which they forgot.
And then we have five-piece.
Comes with a side and a biscuit.
Eight pieces. I feel like
they're getting bigger as I go along.
Look at the size of this tender.
Then we have the 12-piece.
I mean, guys, this is
like a -- look at this!
Did you know they're this big?
This is fantastic.
I love how big these are.
That's what I'm talking
about, Popeyes! Thank you.
And, of course, the 16-piece.
Look at this bad boy.
Look at the size of these guys.
Tenders in the UK come
in four portion sizes.
As a two-piece, which is a kids meal,
as a three-piece, a five-piece,
and an eight-piece.
Next up is the nuggets.
These can be found in servings
of a four-piece kids meal,
a six-piece kids meal, eight-piece,
the 12-piece,
24-piece,
36 pieces.
And then this double pile right here,
the biggest order,
48 pieces.
And I have to say,
does not look like enough.
I know I could destroy that
48-piece with confidence.
What do we got here?
Oh, look at this sticker! This is fun!
Yeah, look at these guys!
Look at this big one playing a saxophone.
How fun is that?
That's cool, right?
In the UK, we actually
call our nuggets bites,
and they come in the following sizes:
As a four-piece, which is a kids meal,
a six-piece, a nine-piece, and a 12-piece.
Unfortunately, we
couldn't get these today.
USA. We got biscuits, baby!
These are the not-cookie biscuits
that have come up before in
other "Food Wars" episodes.
These are the biscuits-biscuits.
And at Popeyes, you can get them in one,
either on its own or probably
with just about every meal.
You can also get them in six.
It's, like, rolling right down here.
And you can also get them in 12.
Just overflowing biscuits over here.
We actually do have biscuits
on the UK Popeyes menu.
If you order it as a
side, you get one biscuit.
In the UK, Jollibee serves
their famous Chickenjoy
in six portion sizes, starting with
a one-piece.
In the US, you can get your Chickenjoy
in five different portions.
A one-piece with a side.
Next up, we've got a two-piece.
A two-piece,
also with a side.
We move to a three-piece.
A three-piece that comes with a side.
I'm so excited to try this.
It's my first-ever taste
of Jollibee fried chicken.
Not my first time, Harry.
Wow, that's good. That's really good.
I don't know how it stayed so crispy.
The next sizes up are buckets of chicken.
You can get a bucket in six
or bucket of 10.
Buckets from a UK Jollibee
come in three sizes,
starting with a six-piece.
Then, from there, we move
up to an eight-piece bucket.
And last but by no means least,
our biggest portion
size is a bucket of 12.
Should've got a bigger plate.
I need some more.
It's really good.
I just love chicken. And
this is a good example of it.
These little crispy bits
that fall off your chicken,
gold dust.
Let's each weigh our
six-piece buckets to see if
the Chickenjoy in one country
is bigger than the other.
It's time for some Jenga.
Ah!
We have over 100 grams more chicken!
[laughs]
I realize this is so arbitrary.
The size of the meat,
the amount of coating.
But it's nice to win, regardless.
The chicken at Jollibee also comes
in the form of tenders. In the UK,
these are served in four portion sizes.
As a single tender.
What? One piece? One piece?
Who's getting one chicken tender?
As two tenders.
As a portion of three tenders.
And, finally, as a portion of four.
One chicken tender. I've
never heard of that. Anywhere.
Well, here in America,
we have normal portion sizes
for our chicken tenders.
You can get them in
three pieces, six pieces.
I think three is not enough, but OK.
Three pieces, six pieces,
10 pieces.
Whoa!
[sighs]
[beep]
Or 16.
Yeah!
Tenders. How do you like that?
Yeah, there's a little
bit more going on now.
I like it. Little bit of heat to it.
The batter seems different.
It has more of the
buttermilk flavor to it,
of the coating.
Yeah.
Garlic mayo. Always.
Who needs ranch when you have garlic mayo?
Who needs garlic mayo when you have ranch?
[boxing bell rings]
Ranch is far superior to
garlic mayo. No question.
Hell, yeah. Love ranch.
A worthy addition.
Ranch is way better.
You got herbs and spices.
Aren't they, like,
basically the same thing?
Then we're on to some
Jollibee specialities.
Now, one iconic dish is this one.
This is the Jolly spaghetti.
Now, this is a dish made of
spaghetti with some cheese
as well as a sweet-style sauce,
which is, I think, made
with banana ketchup
and some meat as well.
And then it's topped with hot-dog slices.
In the UK, this only
comes as one portion size.
That's a cute size you got there, Harry.
But here in the US, we have three sizes,
our regular portion,
our family portion,
and the party portion.
Look at this.
This is supposed to be eight to 10 people.
It's like a lasagna. Look at that.
Now, according to a friend
of mine from the Philippines,
the pro move is to dunk the chicken
into the spaghetti sauce.
So let's give that a try.
The cold cheese isn't doing it any favors,
I'll be honest.
OK.
Yeah.
That's actually not bad.
It's a bit misleading because
their spaghetti is actually,
the sauce is sweet.
Very good. Yeah, together,
that's really good.
Then we're on to the burgers.
Now, Jollibee is famous
for its Yumburgers,
which is a beef burger with
its signature burger sauce.
In the UK, these come as
either a single or as a double.
Over here in the US, you can
get the classic Yumburger
or this, the double Yumburger.
Don't want a bun for your burger, you say?
Jollibee has you covered.
They have something
called the burger steaks.
Patties of burgers smothered
in their mushroom gravy.
You can get them in two
patties, three patties,
or the six-patty family pack.
Over here, the burger steaks
only come as a two-piece.
In the US, you can get
a side of white rice.
We only have one size, and
it's this one right here.
Same here. Our rice just
comes in one portion,
and it's wrapped up like this. Very cute.
Let's start with the starters.
Now, TGI Fridays in the UK and the US
both have lots of starter options.
So what we're going to do is
pick the most popular ones
and compare those. First up,
we have the mozzarella sticks.
An order of these in the
UK contains four sticks.
In the US, our TGI
Fridays mozzarella sticks
come in an order of six. Six sticks.
Or you can get the platter,
which doubles that. 12 sticks.
Harry: We're going to weigh
three UK mozzarella sticks
to try and find the average weight.
Hey, Harry, is that three sticks?
Thought that order had four?
So, three mozzarella sticks
in the UK weighed 95 grams.
That means that each
individual mozzarella stick
weighed an average of 31.6 grams.
Joe: Yes.
So, six sticks is 260 grams.
So that's roughly
43-point-repeating-3 grams per stick.
Now, pro tip.
Weigh your food, then try one.
Mm.
TGI Fridays is running the
mozzarella-cheese-stick game.
They're running the mozz-stick game.
Mm.
The UK does have loaded potato skins,
but they're not currently
serving them due to the pandemic,
as they don't travel
very well for delivery.
However, we were able to
find some in the store.
When they are available
in the restaurants,
they come in serving sizes of six or 12.
Well, we didn't have
that problem in the US,
or maybe we just don't care.
Either way, loaded potato
skins are totally available
at the US TGI Fridays, and
they come in two sizes.
You can get them in eight
or you get the platty boy, which is 12.
Chicken wings in the UK
come in two portion sizes.
As a single portion of three wings
or as a sharing portion,
which is six wings.
♪ Chicken wing, chicken wing ♪
Hey, Harry, when I said
to compare the wings
between the US and the
UK, I meant these wings.
Maybe it's cultural differences,
or maybe I just read the menu wrong.
Anyway.
In the US, our wings
come in an order of 10,
or you can get a platter
of either 30 or 50 wings.
Hell, yeah, dude.
I want to eat every
single one of these wings.
If you like your chicken off the bone,
you can also get boneless
wings at TGI Fridays
in both the UK and the US.
Here, they come in two portion sizes.
As a single, which is 7 ounces,
or as a sharing size, which is 14 ounces.
In the US, our TGI Fridays
offer boneless wings by ounces.
You can get 10 ounces,
40 ounces,
or a platter of 80 ounces!
Look at this. You have no
idea how good this smells.
That is so good!
How are they so good?
The ribs in the UK come in two sizes,
as a half rack or as a full rack.
And both come in either a
legendary or a barbecue glaze.
Our ribs in the US also
come in a half slab
or a full slab.
We're going to weigh
our large portion to see
who out of me or Joe has the biggest rack.
[ba-dum tss]
So, a large rack of ribs in the UK
came to around 366 grams.
Bunch of children over there.
"Joe's rack."
Grow up!
All right, here we go.
Zoop!
Ooh, this guy's already falling apart.
Tender!
And a full slab in the
US is almost 600 grams.
How do you like that?
I got the bigger rack.
Most meals in the UK come with
a side of fries by default,
so we're going to weigh a
regular portion of fries
to see what it comes to.
Joe: Yikes, ours is only 120.
120 for a side of fries in the US.
Hm.
In the UK, Nando's chicken
comes in three serving sizes.
A quarter of a chicken.
In the US, Nando's standard chicken
comes in just two sizes.
There's a half a chicken.
A whole chicken.
Or a fourth of a chicken.
You can get a whole chicken in the US,
but only as part of a platter.
And we're going to weigh the whole chicken
to see which country's
chickens are bigger.
USA chicken, baby!
We can also get bonus thighs in the UK.
If you order these, they
come in a portion of four.
Our thighs actually come
as a portion of three.
So we got one, two, three.
♪ Chicken, chicken wings ♪
♪ They're my favorite
thing, and I love to sing ♪
If you haven't already seen it,
look up the "Nando's Skank,"
which is a very pure
distillation of British culture
in the late '00s.
It's Ed Sheeran and Example rapping
about Nando's in a car
park. I don't know why.
And then he's just flexing his black card,
which I'm fuming about.
'Cause, you know, Nando's black card,
they give them out to select individuals,
and it entitles you to free Nando's,
which I'm so jealous of.
Also, bone to pick with that in general.
Why do they always give the
celebrities the free stuff?
'Cause they're the
people who need it least.
They're already rich.
Sort a guy out. Come on.
I'm not a celebrity.
Not yet.
Next up in the UK, we've got wings.
They come in four portions.
A portion of three.
Our wings come as a serving of 12.
A portion of five.
Or ...
Harry: A portion of 10.
Medha: A serving of 24.
Or a portion of 15.
If chicken on the bone isn't for you,
Nando's also offers chicken
in the form of burgers,
wraps, and pitas. In the UK,
you can get these as
singles or as doubles.
We can also get our chicken wrapped
or burgered.
However, in the US,
there's no option to add double chicken,
which sucks.
It's like a little burrito.
Holy ...
Don't do "Food Wars"
without eating breakfast.
I'm going to cry.
We're going to remove all the toppings
from the single chicken
burger and weigh it
to see how it compares to the US version.
So, we're going to take out
the tomato and the lettuce,
just like Harry mentioned.
Which is good because tomato
does not belong on burgers
and never should.
On the side of your chicken,
it's pretty common to get
some chips at Nando's.
I'm excited for this episode
because I can actually
call them chips for once,
as that's what they're
referred to on the US menu. Suck it, Joe.
Suck it, Joe!
What did I do? Why is everyone
telling me to suck it?
[laughing]
He's not even hosting this episode.
I just gotta send for him.
[beep]
Chips in the UK come in
regular or large sizes.
The standard US sizes
are regular and large.
However, if you get them
as part of a platter,
you can get the bonus extra-large size.
Let's weigh the large fries
to see whose is bigger.
Maybe I should've used the bowl. Oh, no.
I'm still gonna eat these.
I don't care if they
touch all these gross ...
I'm getting too good
at emptying brick chips
from containers.
So, our scale is just about
adequate for this one,
and a portion of large fries in the UK --
I said fries. Why did I say fries?
I'm being conditioned to saying fries.
That's right, buddy.
I heard you say fries!
This show is getting to me.
[beep]
A portion of large chips in the UK
comes to about 498 grams.
Medha: 150 grams.
In the UK, Quiznos sandwiches
come in four sizes.
Firstly, we have the kids
size, which is 4½ inches.
Then we have a small
sub, which is 6 inches.
A medium sub from a UK
Quiznos is 9 inches,
or at least it should
be before we got hungry
and ate it by mistake.
And then finally we have a large sub,
which is 12 inches, or 1 foot long.
In the US, our Quiznos
sandwiches come in four sizes.
The sammie, a 4-inch, an
8-inch, and a 12-inch.
And I want to give Quiznos props
for not calling this,
like, a sandwich taco
or something really obnoxious.
Also in the US at a Quiznos,
you can get party platters
of either 20 3-inch sandwiches
or 14 flatbreads cut in half.
There are no fountain drinks
at a Quiznos in the UK.
Instead, we just have cans and bottles,
which are 330 milliliters and
500 milliliters, respectively.
In the US at a Quiznos,
you can get your drinks in three sizes.
Either a bottle, which is 20 ounces,
the regular, also 20 ounces,
or the large, which they did not have.
Harry: Let's weigh a
classic Italian foot-long
from a Quiznos in the UK
to see what it comes to.
So, our scales could
just about handle that.
Turns out that a foot-long classic Italian
from a UK Quiznos is 520 grams.
Joe: In the US, Quiznos'
classic foot-long Italian
is about, like, 460?
[burps]
Quiznos was one of the first
chains to toast their subs,
so now let's arbitrarily
compare the toastedness
between our bread and the UK bread.
In our extremely precise
comparison metric,
it looks like the US maybe has the edge
when it comes to toastiness of the bread.
The inside of this is completely soggy,
and the outside, just very average.
In the UK, you can get your
order in three portion sizes.
As a small platter, as a regular
platter, or as a sandwich.
The Halal Guys in the US,
your order can come in three sizes.
Small, regular, sandwich.
We're going to weigh a regular
platter in both countries
to see whose is the biggest.
It's been so many episodes.
Why don't we just get bigger scales?
Bear with us. One second.
First half is about 337 grams.
337 plus 321.
658?
Quick maths.
This thing, we need to wash this thing.
It's getting funky in here.
Here we go. The regular.
Fits in perfectly.
640.
640 grams. It's a full meal.
Oh, man, this smells so good.
Fries in the UK only come in
one portion size, this one.
In the US, The Halal Guys
also only have one size fries.
Look at this case. Seen this?
Do you think it's to keep them crispy,
so they don't get soggy?
Very smart. Very innovative.
I wanna eat this so badly.
We gotta weigh it first.
This could be another brick.
Ah.
Hey.
So, a side of fries from a UK Halal Guys
came to 213 grams.
Wait. Oh, yeah. OK.
Yeah.
145 grams for one size
of Halal Guys fries.
Uh, yeah!
Yo.
I've never gotten the
fries. These are good!
Crispy. Don't sleep on
the Halal Guys fries.
In the UK, a side of hummus
only comes in one size,
and it's this one right here.
In the US of A, Halal Guys
hummus only comes in one size,
and of course we are going to weigh it.
Harry: So, our side order of
hummus came in at 246 grams.
I'm going to eat all of this
as soon as the cameras stop rolling.
A side order of baba ghanoush in the UK
only comes in one size as well.
Joe: In the US, the baba
ghanoush at The Halal Guys
is also just one size.
In the UK, you can get a side of falafel,
and it comes as a two-piece serving.
We did ask for some, but
I think the guy forgot,
so we don't have any to show you.
In the US at The Halal Guys,
you can get your falafel in three sizes.
Two pieces, four pieces, or six pieces.
We can also get falafel sandwiches.
Let's take some measurements.
Our falafel sandwich is
8 inches in diameter.
And for the moment you've
all been waiting for,
we're going to measure the girth.
The tape measure is
really not fit to task.
Actually, no. That's kind of worked.
And our falafel sandwich has a girth of,
let's say 7 and a bit inches.
From pita to pita.
8 inches.
Yeah. Oh, look at that!
And it's 8 inches thick. 8 and 8.
I like when things are
just precise like that.
Harry: And finally, it weighs 286 grams.
And a falafel sandwich
at the US Halal Guys
♪ weighs ♪
like, exactly
[burps] excuse me.
Exactly 250 grams.
In the UK, if you want
dessert at Halal Guys,
you can get baklava.
It comes in a two-piece serving.
Halal Guys in the US, the
baklava comes in one size,
in this one piece,
this piece right here.
Oops, I ordered two! I guess
I'll just have to eat one!
Who am I kidding? I'm
eating both of these.
Let's start with the drinks.
In the UK, the majority of hot
drinks only come in one size,
which is 12 ounces.
Pret says this is to optimize efficiency
and to keep things simple for customers.
However, there are two
exceptions to this rule.
Firstly, if you order a
flat white from a UK Pret,
it served as an 8-ounce drink.
Then, if you order an
espresso or a macchiato,
it comes in one of these
adorable little 4-ounce cups.
All right. So, in the US,
our hot coffees come in three sizes.
Small,
medium,
and large.
This is ridiculous.
But we also have some
exceptions to the rules.
Our flat white is only
served as an 8-ounce drink,
but our macchiato is 4
ounces, like the UK's,
and our espresso is
actually just 2 ounces.
I guess they're trying to limit
our caffeine intake. Maybe.
Harry: We're going to measure
our largest black coffee
to find out if you're actually getting
as much as you're told you are.
So, to Pret's credit,
that is exactly 12 ounces.
We are not getting as much
coffee as they say we are,
but maybe that's a good thing.
20's kind of a lot.
Not getting as much coffee
as advertised, huh, Irene?
Welcome to "Food Wars."
What about iced coffees?
Well, in the UK, these
also just come in one size.
Well, over here, we can
get iced black coffee
as either a 16- or 24-ounce serving.
It's a lot of coffee.
I don't get people who drink black coffee.
Harry: We're both going
to measure our largest
iced black coffee to find
out what they come to.
So, once again, this came
to exactly 12 ounces.
So, the iced coffee is also
not the advertised amount.
It's supposed to be 24 ounces,
but it looks like it's only about 21.
It's an international coffee conspiracy!
Season two, we're still dealing with this.
I mean, is someone gonna
do something about this?
Once again, maybe not a bad thing?
I feel like a lot of people are
going to disagree with that.
Do you need this much
caffeine in your life?
Probably.
I don't know if Joe or Harry
drinks this much coffee.
I feel like Joe might.
He seems like he would.
He has that energy.
Joe just looks like he just drinks, like,
five cups of black coffee a day
and then he's up at 2 a.m.
Joe: Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
just, like, haunted.
Yes, I do. I drink a lot of coffee.
I should say that it's only April,
and I've already passed three
kidney stones this year.
What about some of the food options?
This is an egg salad
sandwich from a UK Pret.
We're going to weigh this one
to see how much it comes to.
Irene: It's exactly 250 grams.
Maybe our eggs are heavier.
It's all those preservatives.
If you were raised here,
you wouldn't be worried.
We should probably be worried.
It's not that good.
But I'm hungry.
Egg salad is ♪ gross ♪
Like, it generally doesn't taste good,
but I'm just taking bites of it.
So that was a classic sandwich.
But what about a baguette?
This is a ham and cheese
baguette from a UK Pret.
So, our UK ham and cheese baguette
came to exactly 200 grams.
Well, here's our famous
ham and cheese baguette.
It says it should weigh 251 grams.
It's exactly 251 grams. That's impressive.
It's actually kind of scary.
I know it should weigh exactly
the amount it says it should,
but it's kind of cool
when it actually does.
Next up, we've got this muffin.
This is a double berry
muffin from a UK Pret,
which is a blueberry muffin
with some extra blueberry
compote in the middle.
All right. So, we have our
classic blueberry muffin,
without the extra compote in the middle.
Harry: Let's find out how much it weighs.
Do you know the muffin man?
The muffin man?
The muffin man!
Yes, I know the muffin man
who lives on Drury Lane.
God, I love "Shrek."
Can we get a Harry Shrek?
Can we get Harry's face
turned into Shrek, please?
You know I've never seen "Shrek"?
My surname's an anagram of Shrek.